Sophie Brook joined the Navy for
adventure excitement and responsibility
but the reality she says couldn't have
been further from that claiming she was
bullied harassed and even sexually
assaulted while I was asleep
um in my bed and the first thing
um that I sort of woke up to was like a
bit of a fumble that was going on as a
officer seeing it myself was trying to
get into my bed and kissing me and I
mean I pushed him off and said no that's
no and to be fair he did immediately
um back off when I said no but
um I was pretty shocked to find him
getting into my bed
um in the first place Sophie says the
abuse was constant and came from the top
down and that her name was on a list
compiled by male colleagues ranking
women in the order they'd be raped if
there was a catastrophic event at Sea
eventually it got too much I'd said a
number of times
um
to various people you know I'd rather be
dead than going on this Patrol I knew I
couldn't cope I knew I couldn't do it
and I slammed my arm in the door to try
to break it
because I I knew I wasn't going to cope
on that boat I was self-harming
um to the point of needing stitches
the claims have prompted the head of the
Navy to launch an investigation Admiral
Sir Ben key writing on Twitter these
allegations are abhorrent sexual
assaults and harassment has no place in
the Royal Navy and will not be tolerated
I have directed my senior team to
investigate these allegations thoroughly
anyone who is found culpable will be
held accountable for their actions
regardless of their rank or status
but the scandals also led to calls for
an independent inquiry something even
those who have served in the Navy admit
may be needed let's see how the Navy
does if it doesn't do well in relation
to this in weighing the evidence and
Prosecuting the people concerned that's
absolutely essential uh then we need to
go for an independent review and the
abuse it's claimed is nothing new
allegedly going on for more than a
decade since 2011 when a ban on female
recruits on submarines was lifted we
assisted a woman whose complaint was
only resolved this year she made her
complaint in 2017 and the kinds of
things she was complaining about were
about were very very similar really
really nasty pernicious endemic sexual
harassment nowhere for her to go every
time she tried to raise it through her
chain of command she was blocked and
actually she was seen as the problem but
a wider problem has now been
acknowledged by the ministry of Defense
which said it's improving reporting
mechanisms for sexual offenses it also
accepted that more needs to be done
Ivor Bennett Sky News Crawley